-Ralph, over the years,
there have been a lot of rumors
floating around
about the "Karate Kid" movies.
I have a few here
I'd like your thoughts on.
Sound good?
-I'm good.
-Alright. Let's do it.
It's time for "The Final Word:
Cobra Kai Edition."
-♪ It's "The Final Word:
Cobra Kai Edition" ♪
Alright, first rumor,
"The Karate Kid"
is such an iconic title,
but is it true that
you didn't like it at first?
-That is true. That is true.
We thought -- I thought,
and I was not the only one,
thought it was kind of a hokey,
kind of cheesy title
for a movie being directed
by the guy who made "Rocky"
and all this stuff.
But maybe it was foreshadowing.
I maybe thought
if I ever got the part,
I'd have to carry the damn thing
for the rest of my life.
Maybe that was it.
-And be The Karate Kid, yeah.
Follow-up, what did you think
the movie should've been called?
-If I came up with that great
title, we might've had a shot.
You know, it was called --
-Any bad ones?
-Yeah, I think John Avildsen,
our director, said,
"Maybe it's
'East meets West in West'?"
I was like --
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, we'll have people
do a little math
when they're going
to see the movie.
-Exactly. Like,
what does that mean?
And I think it was called
"The Moment of Truth"
in many countries when "karate"
had a negative connotation
in certain territories.
-Oh, really?
-So it was called
"The Moment of Truth."
-"The Moment of Truth."
I don't mind that one.
-"Moment of Truth II,"
"Moment of Truth --"
It's just not working.
-Yeah, that's true, yeah, yeah.
Alright, here we go, second one.
Everyone knows you
as Daniel LaRusso.
But is it true other people were
considered for the role, too?
-No. Yes.
-I'm assuming, right?
-It was all me.
It was all me all the time.
No, I was found early.
I was cast very early.
But it was like
one of those test deals
where you're not in yet.
And I remember walking by
and seeing Charlie Sheen
hanging outside
Jerry Weintraub's bungalow.
Like, what's Charlie doing here?
And I heard --
-"Hey, bud,
nice to see you again."
-"Yeah, good to see you.
What are you doing here?
You don't look like
an Italian guy from Jersey."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Uh, hey."
And Downey Jr. --
-I heard Nick Cage.
-Nick Cage, I think.
I remember --
Yeah, and Robert Downey Jr.
Robert Downey Jr.
also did the workshop
of the part I did
in "The Outsiders."
So I was doing pretty good
with Downey Jr. at that point,
and then it just --
Like Iron Man, it took off.
-Yeah, what happened to that?
-Nah, it's great.
-Oh, this is an interesting one
they got off the Internet.
And I don't know why.
You have to explain this to me.
Do you write Thor comics?
-Ah, no.
That's another Ralph Macchio.
It's amazing.
I learned about this
when someone was like,
"Dude, love your movies.
Thanks for Thor!"
And I was like, "Okay."
And, "Why were you thanked for
Thor at the end of the movie?"
And I said,
"Let me do some research."
So, there is
a very famous Ralph Macchio
who's a part of Stanley's team
at Marvel and writes comics.
I've never met him. I wonder
if he knows who the hell I am.
-Wow. Amazing. That's wild.
-Isn't that wild?
-I never heard that. Yeah.
At the end of "The Karate Kid,"
you famously win
the All Valley Championship
with the crane kick.
Now, before
we get into it, okay,
I want to show everyone
the scene we're talking about.
Here's the famous crane kick
from "The Karate Kid."
-No mercy! No mercy!
[ Shouts indistinctly ]
Finish him!
♪♪
-Fight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on. Come on!
That was the famous scene from
"East Meets West Goes West."
And -- No, I hate
to bring this up,
but people have asked
this question.
-Do you? Do you really?
Go ahead.
-Yeah, exactly. I think --
Well, no, I have --
-Go ahead.
-This first one, I don't know.
Was the kick actually legal?
-Yes, it's become
an Internet, um, fan theory,
is that the kick was not legal.
Here's my theory.
No, here's the truth.
-Whoa! That's what
I'm talking about. Yes.
-Here's the truth,
'cause it's been a while,
and I've been fighting off
these theories a long time.
Listen, Mr. Miyagi
was the ultimate teacher,
so, and LaRusso had him
as his trainer.
And as the superior trainer --
He's basically the human Yoda --
You don't bet against Yoda.
You don't bet against Miyagi.
That's number one.
Number two, I would say, is that
LaRusso, how did he train?
He trained over a couple of
weeks time by household chores,
never having the ability
or privilege
to have a sparring partner.
His opponent there, bud,
was like, you know,
in combat-ready training
for years for this event.
LaRusso was injured
in the final fight, correct?
-That's true.
-He was injured by an illegal --
-You really have
thought about this.
-Don't get me started.
-Oh, no, I want to! I want to!
-They mentioned
we were going to go here.
An illegal leg sweep
by a teammate of said opponent.
And so, not to mention --
-"Said opponent."
It's like we're in court.
-I'm in a courtroom.
-Your Honor! Your Honor.
-It's "My Cousin Vinny" now.
I've just moved
to another movie.
So, and if you look
at the tape, Jimmy,
if you look at the tape,
not only,
not only does the ref say
"Point, winner" --
A win is a win --
The opponent, who shall remain
nameless at this point,
literally arguably charged,
ran into the kick.
LaRusso had nothing to do
but defend himself.
-There you go.
The kick was legal.
What do you -- True. I agree.
How can you fight --
Case closed on that one.
-I rest my case.
-This one is just --
I think I have my own theory
on this one.
It's not a real theory for me.
Was Daniel LaRusso
really the underdog,
or is he actually
kind of a bully?
-Mm, yeah, that's not even --
Listen, I believe
that no one was not rooting
for Daniel LaRusso in 1984.
I -- Let me do it this way.
I'm using you as an example,
someone of great character
and judgment.
-Thank you.
-Okay, I've seen
more than a handful of sketches
that pay homage
to "The Karate Kid" film.
-Yes.
-You are always wearing
the Miyagi-Do headband.
-Yeah.
-You would never
endorse a bully.
So therein lies
the answer to the question.
-Wow. So there --
See, I would never
endorse a bully, you're right.
-No, you're not putting on
a black headband.
You're putting on
Miyagi's headband,
which is LaRusso's headband,
which is the hero of the --
-Who was an underdog. Thank you.
Daniel LaRusso.
[ Cheers and applause,
both laugh ]
We love you. There you have it.
Ralph, thank you so much
for being --
The new season of "Cobra Kai"
is streaming now on Netflix!